the foundation of this this epidemic
where by the year 2030 one in two people
are going to be not just overweight but
obese it used to be turn of the century
we ate five pounds of sugar per person
per year it's now 150 pounds of sugar
per person per year we're eating like
basically our weight in sugar and the
Obesity rates have gone from point five
percent to over now we're more obese and
overweight insulin makes you hungry it
makes you store belly fat it locks the
fat in the fat cells and it slows your
metabolism it's like a quadruple threat
for your body to gain weight that
fructose is a player it is a big player
I feel amazing I though don't know if
I'm killing myself slowly borderline
diabetes or Frank diabetes mild
elevation and blood sugar or can't lose
that last 20 pounds and they're doing
everything they possibly can darn it I'm
doing everything I can there's got to be
something else this may be that
something else maybe that Missing Link